[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo 30 minutes pour résumer la semaine
écoulée à l'assemblée et au sénat avec
orianne mancini bonjour oriane gentil et
notre invité aujourd'hui et fabienne
keller sénatrice du bas-rhin vous êtes
vice présidente d'agir la droite
constructif bonjour bonjour bonjour
fabienne keller et cette semaine la
sphère benalla a agité le sénat mercredi
alexandre benalla était auditionnée par
la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale plus
de deux heures d'audition durant
laquelle il a présenté ses excuses aux
sénateurs mais cela n'a pas empêché la
poursuite des passes d'armes entre le
sénat et l'exécutif le porte parole du
gouvernement benjamin griveaux a de
nouveau remis en cause la déontologie de
la commission denquête l'assemblée
nationale fait sauter le verrou de bercy
ce dispositif controversé d'un à
l'administration le monopole des
poursuites pénales en cas de fraude
fiscale
désormais à certaines conditions
l'administration devra dénoncé
automatiquement à la justice les
dossiers des gros fraudeurs fiscaux
et puis l'ambiance était au compromis
entre députés et sénateurs sur la loi
élan après un an de vifs débats et de
divergence entre les deux chambres
un accord a été trouvé mercredi après
six heures de discussions
objectif affiché de cette loi construire
plus mieux et moins cher et on commence
bien sûr avec le temps fort de la
semaine l'audition d'alexandre benalla
au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela a commencé par de longues excuses
envers les sénateurs cela s'est
poursuivi par une série d'explications
sur son rôle à l'elysée l'ancien chargé
de mission d' emmanuel macron a donc été
entendu au sénat mercredi 2h30
d'audition au cours desquelles alexandre
benalla a déroulé un discours
visiblement bien huilée il a fallu toute
la sagacité des sénateurs pour que la
machine sans roues un peu sur les
questions de port d'armes notamment le
résumé est signé quentin calme et aux
premières heures du jour une importante
file d'attenté se forme devant le sénat
ils sont plus de 130 journalistes
mercredi à vouloir assister à cette
audition
face à cette importante nuée de caméras
alexandre benalla se présente de solides
arguments
une ferveur médiatique phénoménale que
même les sénateurs immortalise
visiblement très préparé l'ex chargé de
mission semble en parfaite maîtrise de
ses moyens
pourtant depuis plusieurs jours la
polémique n'a cessé d'enfler
alexandra benalla employant des mots
violents contre les sénateurs
premier acte donc pour son audition de
mercredi matin s'excuser j'ai un profond
regret pour le propos que j'ai pu avoir
à votre rencontre monsieur le président
parce que en quelles que soient les
circonstances
quelle que soit la pression on s'en
prend pas aux hommes mais très vite
après cet acte de contrition alexandre
benalla se montre ferme sur son rôle à
l'elysée en minimisant son importance au
château non il n'était pas le garde du
corps d'emmanuel macron ce n'était pas
une fonction opérationnelle de sécurité
c'était une fonction administrative la
mission de police n'est pas un préalable
à la délivrance de l'autorisation de
port d'armé il est prévu par les textes
de code de la sécurité intérieure en
espèces que peut se voir délivrer tout
fonctionnaire exposés à des risques dans
le cadre de ses fonctions
une autorisation de port d'armes par le
préfet territorialement compétent à la
sortie de l'audition les sénateurs se
montrent très sceptiques
selon toutes ces explications ont été
cadrés en haut lieu où le sent bien
qu'il a été coaché qu'ils auront la
fournit des éléments de langage mais il
ya eu des moments où effectivement pu
très bien se retrouver dans
c'est beaucoup ayant les réponses qu'il
peut apporter on a eu une longue
audition dont les réponses étaient
parfaitement en cohérence avec les
réponses du secrétaire général de la
présidence du directeur de cabinet du
chef de cabinet du président de la
république
le problème c'est que c'est pas cohérent
avec la réalité c'est pas cohérent avec
eux sa situation ses gestes et attitudes
professionnelles lors des déplacements
restent donc d'importantes
contradictions dans cette affaire mais
avec cette audition alex aubenas a
marqué des points en terme d'image
fabienne keller questions simples
qu'avez vous retenu vous de cette
audition
écouter le cd a fait son travail d'abord
en auditionnant les principaux acteurs
de cette affaire
moi cette audition elle je n'aime rien
appris comme la plupart des français
effectivement il était très contrôlée
dans sa prise de parole
mais on le comprend vu la pression
médiatique qui là qu'il vit mais vu
aussi tout ce qu'il a déjà dit puisqu'il
a fait de grandes interviews donc c'est
un grand professionnel pas seulement de
la sécurité mais aussi de la
communication ceci dit les choses se
sont apaisées par rapport à la situation
avant l'été le sénat fait son travail la
commission va rendre son rapport
et c'est important parce que cela a
inquiété les français la question de
l'organisation de la sécurité à l'elysée
au plus haut niveau de l'état
voilà c'est une affaire qui méritait que
le sénat clarifie les rapports de
responsabilité et les prises de décision
me dites que vous n'avez rien appris du
coup est ce que cette audition a été
utile et puis on entendu un les
sénateurs à la sortie de l'audition
françois grosdidier dit s'être fait
balader
pierre charon a dit alexandre benalla se
fout de nous est ce que c'est aussi
votre sentiment
disons qu'on a l'impression qu'on le
revoit bien dans les images d'une
audition très contrôlée avec des mots
voilà pesé peut-être aussi un souci de
cohérence avec les précédentes auditions
qui est très marqué puisque je dois dire
que pour ma part ce qui m'a le plus
troublé ces - les faits c'est une
personne voilà qui dérape
monsieur benalla que au début des
auditions des contradictions qui
apparaissent entre les différents
responsables dont
on avait déjà senti dans les dernières
auditions une grande cohérence une
reprise des paroles des uns des autres
et alexandre ménard a fait la même chose
il s'est remis en cohérence avec les
explications données jusque-là à nouveau
le sénat et l'assemblée nationale
rendront leur rapport
et puis sur l'aspect judiciaire
proprement dit la justice fera en toute
indépendance son travail je crois que
les français ont droit à la vérité que
toute la lumière soit faite
1 le président du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée christian
jacob a déclaré que cette audition
n'avait pas permis selon lui d'obtenir
de réponse sur cette question de quels
moyens de pression dispose alexandre
benalla auprès du président de la
république pour que celui ci soit aussi
fébrile est-ce que vous avez aussi le
sentiment que c'est la question qui
reste en suspens la protection supposé
accordé à alexandre benalla alors ce qui
ce qui explique la mobilisation des deux
assemblées
c'est bien sûr la très grande proximité
qu'on a vu à travers des photos dans des
circonstances très variés pendant la
campagne présidentielle et depuis entre
alexandre benalla et le président de la
république c'est bien cela qui a
justifié que nos assemblées se
mobilisent et essaye de comprendre
prendre part dont pas tant ce qui s'est
passé le premier mais cela relève de la
justice
mais comment est organisé l'élysée et
comment est assurée la sécurité
voilà du chef de l'état dont la personne
ne plus la plus sensible la plus
importante de notre pays
je laisse la responsabilité de ces
paroles à christian jacob
nous au sénat on est plutôt dans la
sérénité on veut clarifier dans
l'intérêt de l'organisation du pays
faut pas non plus donner une importance
excessive à cette affaire il faut la
remettre à sa place mais il faut que la
clarté soit faite
alors voilà pour le pour le contenu de
l'audition mais autour de l'événement
une autre passe d'armes politique s'est
jouée le jour même entre l'exécutif et
le sénat lors du compte rendu du conseil
des ministres le porte-parole du
gouvernement benjamin griveaux a visé
personnellement le président les
républicains de la commission denquête
philippe bas c'était juste après
l'audition écoutez moi je considère que
lorsqu'on est président d'une commission
denquête sans doute est il heureux de
s'exprimer assez peu dans la presse tant
que la commission n'a pas poursuivi ses
travaux jusqu'à son terme
c'est la plus élémentaire des
déontologique d'être le président
impartiale d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire et je sais moi le sérieux
de ce qu'est une commission d enquête
parlementaire il en a eu des célèbres
dans l'histoire de la république
d'ailleurs souvent composés en président
d'un manque de la majorité des membres
de l'opposition
je constate qu'il n'y a que des membres
de l'opposition qui préside cette
commission denquête gouvernement au
sénat n'était pas le cas à l'assemblée
nationale mais j'ai en mémoire ce soit
la commission cahuzac la commission
outreau souvenez vous ces travaux qui
avaient été portées sur une affaire
extrêmement délicate sensible difficile
et bien où les présentes s'exprime pas
dans la presse tant que les travaux
n'avaient pas été menées jusqu'à leur
terme
je crois que c'est là aussi un code de
déontologie que chacun devrait
s'appliquer avec keller alexandre
benalla a présenté ses excuses aux
sénateurs au début de l'audition pensait
que l'heure était à l'apaisement est ce
que cette phrase de benjamin griveaux
était opportune je ne le pense pas je
suis très surprise que le porte parole
du gouvernement remette en cause un civ
l'expression qui doit être libre du
président de la commission d'enquêté de
la commission des lois puisque je
rappelle que c'est la commission des
lois du sénat qui s'est installée en
commission denquête c'est pour ça qu'il
ya qu un seul président voilà c'est
comme ça mais ça permet aussi que des
personnes très impliquées sur des sujets
juridiques voilà soient mobilisés c'est
plus plus simple plus respectueux des
missions de chacun donc je suis étonné
de ces paroles de benjamin griveaux
voilà le sénat est une instance qui est
autonome c'est un des piliers de la
république il faut respecter son son
travail voilà lui s'exprime publiquement
monsieur bénard a fait des interviews
philippe bas plutôt été très sobre dans
son expression publique et il assure la
mission de contre-pouvoir de deux
grandes assemblées qui est celle du
sénat et je trouve que le sénat est
honorée d'avoir une attitude très apaisé
des auditions respectueuse des gens
missionné qui ont apporté des éléments
pour celle du mois de juillet au la
compréhension de ce qui s'est passé et
je ne comprends pas cette fébrilité du
gouvernement qui c'est vrai alimentent
l'idée qu' il ya quelque chose quoi
hélas pas été le seul benjamin griveaux
attaqué le sénat est ce que vous pensez
que cette affaire va laisser des traces
entre le sénat l'exécutif je pense que
c'est très étonnant quand c'est le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement si le juge christophe castaner
qu'il qui le juge enfin qu'il donne des
avis sur le fonctionnement interne du
sénat il va respecter le sénat essayez
plutôt de travailler dans le respect de
nos institutions républicaines
au moment où en europe on dit que voilà
il ya des sujets sur le respect des
institutions de l' équilibre des
pouvoirs de la liberté d'expression je
pense qu'il faut au volant faut être
très très attentif aux as que la france
soit soit exemplaire dans l'indépendance
des pouvoirs
on va passer à un autre sujet fabienne
keller puisque mercredi l'assemblée
nationale a fait sauter le verrou de
bercy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a quasi unanimité les députés ont
voté à la fin pour les plus gros
fraudeurs du monopole des poursuites
détenu jusqu'ici par l'administration
fiscale
désormais les dossiers devons être
automatiquement transmis à la justice
le gouvernement salue une avancée
décisive et historique
mais pour certains membres de
l'opposition cela ne va pas assez loin
alexandre pérou la fin d'un débat vieux
de plusieurs décennies pour sandoz
contre 0 l'assemblée nationale a adopté
mercredi à la quasi unanimité
l'assemblée nationale a fait sauter le
très décrié verrou de bercy instauré par
la jurisprudence dans les années 20 le
dispositif permettait à l'administration
fiscale de ne pas transmettre un dossier
de fraude à la justice une suppression
que certains réclamaient depuis des
années
eh bien on y est arrivé voyez pour 20
ans pour une fois on peut dire que
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale s'est montrée dire de la
fonction qui notre première fonction qui
est votée la loi essayer de concilier la
justice pour tous et l'efficacité dans
la répression de la fraude pourtant
réticent au départ le ministre des
comptes publics gérald darmanin s'est
félicité du vote des députés
l'avancé n'est pas importante
elle est décisive et il ne s'agit pas
d'un changement de serrure c'est
vraiment la fin dav et rouky et je
voudrais dire que c'est pas le moindre
des paradoxes n'existait pas dans la loi
les dossiers de fraude fiscale seront
désormais automatiquement transmis aux
juridictions mais seulement si le
montant de cette fraude est supérieur à
cent mille euros
un seuil que ne comprennent pas certains
députés de gauche
pourquoi conserver ne serait ce qu'un
bout de ce monopole jalousement gardé
par les ministres de l'économie est
définie str des finances qui se sont
succédé un monopole qui empêche la
justice de notre pays de se saisir des
cas graves de fraude fiscale
cet aménagement du verrou de bercy
permettra néanmoins de double
le nombre de dossiers transmis chaque
année à la justice et une colère ce
dispositif date de 1920 c'est une
spécificité française il était temps de
remettre en cause oui il était temps
parce que là aussi comme sur le sujet
précédent c'est le respect de la justice
qui doit pouvoir connaître ces fraudes
fiscales je crois que la décision qui a
été prise en fait d'un commun accord
entre les deux assemblées c'est le sénat
qui avait fait cette proposition
permettra aussi à la justice de traiter
ces affaires puisque ce sel est plus
importante
puisqu'à la question des moyens si
toutes les fraudes fiscales
quand il y en a cinquante mille en
france chaque année été transmises
peut-être que ça poserait un problème de
traitement donc une première
une première série un premier ensemble
de fraude les plus importantes ce qui
permettra peut-être de continuer dans le
temps à faire évoluer ce dispositif et a
levé plus largement ce verrou d'un autre
côté je dois dire que l'admission si
l'administration fiscale les finances
publiques c'est quand même une très
belle administration à laquelle je fais
confiance pour ma part pour assurer même
si c'est en interne les poursuites
donc je trouve que c'est une voie là
c'est un bon équilibre et un respect
aussi quand même de la justice qui a été
ainsi construit conjointement par les
deux assemblées
alors justement on a entendu quand même
nombre de députés à gauche mais aussi à
droite dire qu'on était arrivés au
milieu du gué finalement avec cette
proposition et que les critères fixés
restait encore trop laxistes ou vous
vous êtes aussi de cet avis pourquoi
garder une part de l'hérault finalement
alors pour ce que j'évoquais à l'instant
c'est à dire des raisons un peu
d'organisation concrètes
ce contentieux financier souvent très
complexes les fraudes fiscales
aujourd'hui font intervenir des
transferts dans dans des banques des
pays du monde souvent multiples donc
qu'il y à déjà une première salve on
parle de 2000 dossiers de plus
un doublement ou à un triplement du
nombre de dossiers voilà ça permettra de
voir comment la justice peut travailler
avec quelques opérations avec le
ministère des finances avant
probablement enfin moi je le souhaite
une transmission plus systématique de
ces dossiers
en tout cas une avancée je pense pour la
démocratie et le respect des pouvoirs au
delà du verrou de bercy les débats on
s'y était marquée à l'assemblée par
l'adoption d'une alternative aux
poursuites judiciaires pour les
entreprises qui ont fiscalement frauder
en clair une société pourra payer une
amende afin d'éviter des poursuites sans
reconnaissance de culpabilité est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une incohérence d'un côté
on remet de la justice dans le processus
et de l'autre on enlève alors il ya en
matière de fiscalité des natures de
contentieux très très différentes
les entreprises peuvent faire des
erreurs elles peuvent optimiser
fiscalement à la limite de ce qui est
normal c'est ce qu'on appelle l'abus de
droit
est-ce qu'il faut forcément judiciariser
ces procédures ou donner une amende pour
permettre la poursuite de l'activité de
l'entreprise parce que c'est ça le sujet
je pense qu'une telle un tel dispositif
n'est pas dénuée d'intérêt pour
l'économie mais il faudra l'évaluer très
rapidement pour voir si effectivement il
assure quand même un respect des
principes de sanctions et de
judiciarisation si les faits sont graves
et s'il n'y a pas d'abus très bien on en
vient à notre troisième thème cet accord
survenu entre députés et sénateurs sur
la loi logement
[Musique]
le texte devrait être définitivement
voté d'ici à la fin septembre le sénat
et l'assemblée sont donc arriver à une
version commune de la loi dite élan
après sept heures de discussions
mercredi
un consensus a pu être retrouvée sur les
270 articles de ce texte fleuve
explications flora sauvage c'est
l'aboutissement d'un an de débats
houleux
l'ambiance était au compromis mercredi
soir lors de la commission mixte
paritaire sur la loi élan alors que le
gouvernement s'était montrée inflexible
fin juillet lors de l'examen du texte
par la haute assemblée
les députés de la république en marche
on fait des concessions vis-à-vis des
sénateurs première concession sur la
part de logements accessibles aux
personnes handicapées dans les
programmes neufs les députés voulaient
qu'elle soit fixée à 10% au lieu de 100
% actuellement
finalement cette part est relevée à 20%
autre point de divergence la question du
logement social
le gouvernement demande aux bailleurs
sociaux 1,5 milliard d'euros d'économies
chaque année d'ici à 2020 pour financer
ces économies le gouvernement veut
encourager la vente de hlm sur
l'obligation de 25 % de logements
sociaux fixé par la loi sru
l'objectif a été fixé à 2025 enfin la
loi prévoit d'expérimenter des
mutualisations entre communes
l'objectif d'un quart de logements
sociaux sera au niveau de
l'intercommunalité
concernant les plus démunis députés et
sénateurs se sont accordés pour créer un
dispositif d'occupation temporaire des
bâtiments vacants
mais les sénateurs ont aussi introduit
avec l'accord des députés des pénalités
de retard
si le locataire ne paie pas son loyer à
temps et des sanctions pénales pour les
squatteurs de résidences principales ou
secondaires viennent quel est ce que
c'est un bon compromis qui a été trouvé
entre députés et sénateurs
alors d'abord le principe du compromis
est plutôt constructif c'est quelque
chose d'intéressant parce que ça
respecte deux assemblées qui représente
le peuple
et puis plus tôt les élus locaux
s'agissant du du sénat donc je pense que
c'est une bonne méthode plutôt que ce
qui a été le cas sur d'autres textes où
tout le travail du sénat était balayée
c'est je pense une perte de
lien avec avec le terrain même si comme
mes collègues voilà c'est ce qui se
passe quand hier un compromis moi je ne
partage pas toutes les décisions je suis
en particulier très réservé sur la
réduction du pourcentage de logements
accessibles
je pense que 100% c'était une bonne un
bon choix puisque en fait c'est
seulement sur les logements neufs
il y à tous les logements existants qui
pour la plupart ne sont pas accessibles
va peut être préciser que le quota
désormais de nouveaux logements seront
réservés aux handicapés seront 100%
évolutif mais que seuls 20 % sont
directement adaptées alors on précise
que le gouvernement voulait seulement
10% 12% voilà le gouvernement était
parti d'une base très basse on verra ce
que ça veut dire un logement évolutif et
puis il faut toujours penser que les
personnes porteuses de handicap
certes il ya leur logement mais elles
vont voir leurs amis donc il est
important que voilà il puisse aller voir
tout le monde donc dans un dans une mise
à niveau en accessibilité de l'ensemble
du parc
cette réduction je sais qu'elle était
demandé pour des raisons de coût mais
elle est pénalisante pour
l'accessibilité à terme de l'ensemble du
parc de la même manière les
regroupements forcés de société des hlm
avec un seuil très élevé douze mille
logements
certes moins élevé que ce que voulait le
gouvernement à 15000 mais ça veut dire
que dans un certain nombre de
départements où les sociétés sont plus
petites plus modestes parce que le
territoire est moins densément peuplées
eh ben ça va forcer de gros
rassemblements
je trouve qu'on est quand même toujours
dans le paradigme de la taille au
gouvernement et que parfois on gère bien
en proximité une structure à taille
humaine alors les sénateurs ont aussi
réaffirmé le rôle des maires en matière
d'urbanisme le gouvernement voulait les
contourner oui puisque cette loi crée
deux nouveaux dispositifs d'aménagement
et les maires n'était pas consulté pour
valider ces projets le maire et
vis-à-vis de la population responsable
responsable de de tous - on l'a vu cela
cet été à travers le blues des mères
il faut donc leur permettent de donner
leur avis sur tout l'aménagement c'est
une mission noble une mission importante
on ne pouvait pas imaginer que leur
commune évolue fortement sens qu'il
participe à la discussion
allez on en vient au reste de
l'actualité parlementaire avec d'abord
une élection à l'assemblée celle du
nouveau président du groupe la
république en marche
c'est gilles legendre qui a été élu en
remplacement de richard ferrand devenu
président de l'assemblée le député de
paris proche de richard ferrand était
déjà vice-président du groupe à demi mot
il a promis de se démarquer de son
prédécesseur en laissant plus de place
au débat au sein de ses troupes on est
quoi nous sommes absolument tous unis
maintenant pour aller de l'avant
nous savons aussi ça a été l'objet d'un
certain nombre de départs en prenant
qu'un certain nombre de pratiques
d'habitude de fonctionnement pouvaient
évoluer au sein du groupe je me suis
engagé et je les mènerai avec alors
c'est un homme discipliné discret
éditons proche de richard ferrand est ce
que ce choix de gilles legendre c'est le
choix d'un homme qui ne fera pas de
vagues
je ne fais pas partie de la république
en marche donc j'ai pas d'avis à donner
sur le le scrutin je relève néanmoins
que sur deux postes très importants la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale et
la présidence du groupe à l'occasion de
ce changement
il n'y a pas eu de femme qui a été
retenu et on voit bien que quand il ya
plusieurs commissions alors on arrive à
faire moins soit mais pour les postes de
pouvoir
le vieux monde est toujours présent et
pourtant la majorité invente la parité
au gouvernement vante le fait que dans
le groupe
casilli 47% des députés sont des femmes
c'est une parité de trompe-l'oeil basse
et le plafond de verre qui est à
l'oeuvre
comme toujours quand il ya un poste eh
ben il est là il fonctionne et c'est
ainsi pour ma part je le regrette parce
que je crois qu'il avait des personnes
les femmes de grande qualité qui s'était
également porté à la présidence du
groupe mais à nouveau cédé à faire
plutôt interne à la république en marche
on va terminer cette émission avec les
députés les républicains qui étaient
réunis cette semaine à divonne les bains
pour leurs journées parlementaires
laurent wauquiez le président du parti
étaient présents il a vivement attaqué
emmanuel macron le président des villes
couper des territoires selon lui mettent
aussi également revenu sur son thème de
prédilection l'immigration on écoute et
je le dis parce que c'est ma conviction
il n'y a pas de droits de l'homme a
émigré dans un pays de son choix
il n'est pas normal que ce soient les
passeurs et les mafias qui décide de qui
s'installe sur le sol européen
il n'est pas normal que ce soit les
juges qui tranche à la place des
habitants de ce pays et à la place des
élus de ce pays ce sont aux français de
décider et il est temps de sortir des
hypocrisies
le président de la république ne prend
pas l'aquarius dans les ports français
mais il prend les migrants de l'aquarius
dans nos villes toute l'hypocrisie de sa
politique est ainsi résumé fabienne
keller laurent wauquiez a beaucoup fait
parler de lui cette semaine en déclarant
au figaro que
viktor orban le premier ministre
hongrois avait toute sa place au sein du
parti populaire européen on rappelle que
viktor orban est accusé de porter
atteinte à l'état de droit et de bafouer
les libertés dans son pays que pensez
vous de cette prise de position
elle marque une fracture majeure à
l'intérieur même des républicains
puisque s'agissant de viktor orban
certains ont voté l'article au sed c'est
à dire la poursuite d'une procédure pour
entrave à l'état de droit en hongrie on
parle de quoi on parle de la liberté de
la presse de l'indépendance de la
justice de poursuites contre des
personnes sans respect de leurs droits
donc c'est vraiment fondamental donc
laurent wauquiez porte une lourde
responsabilité
c'est que ils marquent ce clivage est sa
position personnelle c'est que l'état de
droit n'est pas prioritaire c'est que un
prétendu accord au sein du ppe pour lui
est plus important que le respect des
piliers fondamentaux qui fédère
l'ensemble des états membres de l'union
européenne donc c'est tout à fait
inadmissible pour moi c'est tout à fait
inadmissible pour nous qui avons fait le
choix de quitter les républicains et de
créer un nouveau mouvement agir ce sont
les constructif
d'ailleurs le week end dernier à la fois
alain juppé et jean pierre raffarin sont
venus nous dire combien ce respect des
fondamentaux républicains ses
fondamentaux des droits de l'homme était
essentiel dans la perspective de
l'avenir de l'europe
alors pourquoi forme alain juppé ne
franchit pas le pas et ne quitte pas
définitivement les républicains qu'il a
plus renouvelé sa cotisation je crois
qu'il prend progressivement ses
distances
je crois qu'il ya un débat au sein des
républicains c'est valérie pécresse qui
porte une autre vision elle ad'ailleurs
était très secoué lors du dernier
politique moi ça me rappelle de très
mauvais souvenirs au moment d exclusion
donc j'ai le sentiment que les
républicains ne s'en sortent pas de ce
débat il n'arrive pas à construire de
nouvelles perspectives
merci beaucoup merci leur merci d'avoir
été notre invité cette semaine marc
citti bon merci et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition par le manque d'eau
[Musique]